I initiate
if I decide that I put this hand
underneath
and I and I do that his hand will come
out
there's an easy way of testing it if you
think what way did he have his hand up
there's an easy way of testing it
your hand gums underneath you make a
cross like with your fingers don't link
your fingers together because you could
break your fingers but you just push
them together you ask it to take his
hand out
who gets it out
Tunisia if you put your hand on top you
link you ask him to take his hand out
okay there's your answer so when in
doubt just try one on top or one below
you don't need to use any more pressure
[Applause]
so when in doubt
try both method it's too easy to just oh
I'll stick it underneath
he takes his hand out you're left with
nothing only a headache
on top
on top it cuts down
your Tammy
then you turn your hipsy then it's
powerful
we're not ready for the ukami yet
huh
see the last part very important
the side that is close to him must the
hand must be on the bottom
a lot of people say oh it's a free hand
I just take hold of it there this is
incorrect
must be on the bottom
this way when you pick it up it has the
cross like the Ken
has the cross
right looking
there's a lot in those now all the time
hey
and the last part this is the powerful
bit just there
hand is on the bottom
let's try again
if you just come in here
you try to get your hand over the top by
this time
he's been doing karate for 40 years he
kicks you to death
so
this is the motion
ah
the two go together
you can do it like this
to make yourself secure so if you're
still having problems
this hand put on top
go out to the side and turn your feet
so if you're still having problems
foreign
you can do this
this is the real way
and you pin them down
if you think you've got that far you can
do the ukemi
all right
if you don't think you've got that far
[Music]
ah just get to the
and then step and turn and get to there
if you think you can do that oh you
can't do that
you cross your arm
one
two
to uh
okay no more someone's seen you to
myself now there's two ways of
approaching the technique
I want to do hard training but there's
hard training involved
in the way of my attitude so it's ah
that's hard training
because what you're doing is you're
putting full commitment in
that's the difference if I go
oh he wasn't with me so you can't have
hard training if you're Shadow Boxing
the I could tell you need
and you need to pin them down and have
them that's hard trying because 10 of
those and you should be puffing you know
you should be sweating
because you put full commitment
and it doesn't matter whether it's a low
grade a high grade a senior younger this
is a commitment you don't think
um ah I got to be real careful this is
you know person older than myself I'll
I'll just be real gentle with him
I'll bend a bit more for him because he
might not better Bend
well I'll carefully put him down
my Aikido techniques going out the
window and I've not respected him
I need to ah
because it might thank you
hey my